-Donald Trump called
on Republicans
to defund the FBI and DOJ
after he was arrested
and arraigned on
34 felony charges Tuesday.
Meanwhile, Republicans
are threatening retaliation
by openly admitting
they'll use the justice system
to go after Joe Biden.
For more on this, it's time
for A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Donald Trump's allies have spent
the last few days claiming Trump
is actually enjoying the media
spectacle around his indictment
and even the process
of surrendering himself
for arrest.
-Trump, for his part,
is reportedly
downplaying his predicament
behind closed doors,
according to a new story
in The New York Times,
the former president
has told friends and associates
that he welcomes the idea
of being paraded around
by the authorities,
surrounded by the media.
Trump has also reportedly
mused openly
about whether to smile
for the cameras
during a possible perp walk
and described the potential
situation as a fun experience.
-Oh, it's going to be a fun
experience is definitely a lie
you tell people
when you were scared [bleep].
That's 100% what I would say
right before skydiving.
This is going to be so great.
I just can't decide
if I'm going to smile or not.
[ Laughter ]
The only way you could
possibly find the experience
of getting arrested fun
is if everything about your life
is absolutely miserable,
which I guess applies
to Donald Trump.
I mean, look at him.
That was taken right after
someone said they were free
donuts in the break room.
The man is constantly enraged,
and I know I'm wasting
my time saying this,
but I think a person
describing a perp walk
as a fun experience
is disqualifying
for the office of president.
So put that on my list
that nobody gives [bleep] about,
right after stared at an eclipse
and right before called
Apple CEO Tim Cook, Tim Apple.
Nothing -- Nothing involving the
criminal justice system is fun.
Oh, sure.
You might think --
you might think it's fun to be
one of the guys they bring in
to fill out a police lineup.
Well, I used to do that
for a little extra money
back in the day,
and it was fun
till the day I got fingered
for the liquor store
that B.J. Novak knocked over.
[ Laughter ]
Should have known it was him,
because you know
what he did
to the security camera?
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump thought
it would be fun
to be arraigned
in New York City.
Nothing involving the criminal
justice system is fun,
especially in New York.
If they told me
I won the lottery,
but I have to go to
the Manhattan courthouse
to pick up the check
I think,
"I don't mind working."
But here's one thing
I could tell you.
Just as an outside observer
who has watched Donald Trump
for many years now,
the man is not having fun.
For one thing, he wasn't
paraded around by authorities.
He mopped through the hallways
of the criminal courthouse
surrounded by officers
who didn't even hold
the door open for him.
He had to hold the door open,
and that's probably
the first time in his life
he's had to do that.
If Trump walked up to a door
without anyone else
around to help,
he'd be totally stumped.
"Oh, boy. Okay, now,
what are we looking at here?
I should remember this
from my real estate days.
Rectangular, little shape,
tiny metallic pumpkin.
Not sure what
the little pumpkin does.
You know what?
I'm just going to try.
Door open.
Let's see if that works.
Excuse me. Excuse me, door.
You're being a very nasty door.
You're a biased --
you're a biased left wing door.
They gave me a Hillary door.
Hashtag fake door."
But when you actually
look at
Donald Trump's face sitting down
in that courtroom,
you can tell this is not
a man who's having fun.
I mean, look at him.
That's how I look
when I fall asleep on the couch
and wake up after dark.
Again, it's worth
taking in this image
because whatever else
you want to say about it,
it's definitely historic.
This is a former president
sitting in a criminal court
as a defendant surrounded
by his legal team.
The only thing that was missing
was a record scratch,
followed by
an internal monologue.
[ Record scratches ]
"Yep, that's me.
You're probably
wondering how I got here.
Well, sit back, because
it's a pretty crazy story."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So Trump and his team
wanted us all to think
he was enjoying the experience,
that it was fun
and that it would benefit him
politically, which is BS.
This is all part
of the shtick.
Trump wants us to think
everything he does is by design,
that it's all part
of his master plan,
that he's playing
four dimensional chess
and he's always getting
the best of us
and he's loving
every minute of it.
But it's not true.
I mean, look at him.
He's used to sitting
with kings and CEOs,
and now he's sitting in a chair
that five minutes
before he walked in was used
by a guy who pled not guilty
to one charge
of exposing himself
to a squirrel in Central Park.
"Sorry, Your Honor. I just
thought that squirrels liked --"
"No. Will you please
advise the defendant to refrain
from making jokes
about his nuts?
I assure you, this being
the Manhattan Criminal Court,
we've heard all
the nuts jokes before.
Alright, Bailiff.
Next [bleep] case."
That's just how judges
talk in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we're on the next card,
Wally.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me tell you something.
Wally -- Wally Feresten,
best in the biz.
When it comes to cue cards.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But [bleep] crapped out here
there hard.
It was a real brain freeze
by Wally.
-It sounded like an ad-lib.
-It sounded like an ad-lib?
-Yeah, so it was so good.
-All those words
were on the card, Wally.
-Yeah,I know.
-You know, I don't come up
with my own ideas, Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Sal puts them in my head.
But that's why this image
is so important.
It shows that even a guy
who is not too long ago,
the most powerful man
in the world,
the guy who controlled
our nuclear arsenal
and rode around
in a presidential limo
and entered every room
to hail to the chief,
had to sit in that courthouse
in front of a judge
just like everyone else
accused of breaking the law.
In fact, if you ask me,
they should have made
a real New York experience
and towed his plane
while he was inside.
"Rudy?
Rudy, what the [bleep]?"
"Sorry, boss.
I could have sworn I put enough
quarters in the meter.
Although they might
have been my buttons.
Was getting arrested as much fun
as you thought it would be?"
[ Laughing ] In fact,
he's been freaking out --
"I know you
were really excited."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, he's been freaking out
so much that today
he wrote in an all caps
social media post...
It's going to be so funny
the next time a Republican tries
to pretend this never happened
and claims
Democrats are the ones
who want to defund the police.
Joe Biden should have
this post printed out
and wear it like a sandwich
board wherever he goes.
"Donald Trump wants to defund
the police,
and $5 footlongs,
they're back.
They were gone
and I brought them back now.
They're back.
They're back, Jack.
$5 footlong.
$5.
I brought them back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chips are extra."
Now, as for the merits
of the case,
we did learn a lot more from
the charging document yesterday,
like the fact
that Trump finalized the details
of the scheme
with his fixer,
Michael Cohen
in the Oval Office,
or the fact that Trump
also thanked another key player
in the scheme,
former National Enquirer
publisher David Pecker.
During his presidential
transition,
invited him to both
the inauguration
and dinner
at the White House.
Those revelations make clear
that this is not just a case
about Trump having an affair
or even paying hush money,
which, if done right,
is not a crime.
Despite the fact
that Trump's allies on Fox
have all tried
to make it sound like this
was just a silly
bookkeeping error,
or that it's something that
happens all the time.
You're going to break 200 years
of U.S. precedent
about indicting
your political opponents
over a business records charge?
-We were told by the Democrats
in the media
that your private life's
your private life.
Everything was consensual.
Now, all of a sudden,
consensual is a felony
and they're literally
prosecuting
the former president
over sex?
-In fact, settlements like this,
whatever you think of them,
are common,
both among famous people,
celebrities and in
corporate America.
The result is usually known
as an NDA,
a non-disclosure agreement.
In this case,
you can believe
whatever side
you want to believe,
but paying people
not to talk about things,
"hush money," is ordinary in
modern America.
-This must have cost the
taxpayers of New York
tens of millions of dollars,
the security coverage
for this situation.
And you just said it.
over what?
Over $130,000,
completely legal
non-disclosure
agreement payment.
You know, these things
happen all day,
every day in the United States
of America.
-That's not a defense.
That's a confession.
If you think -- if you think
illegal hush money payments
happen all the time,
you're telling us an awful lot
about how the wealthy elite
in this country operate.
"Come on, who among us
has an accidentally
strangled the butler
and buried them in the garden?
It happens all the time.
I'm on my third butler
this month."
But think about that, though.
They went from saying
Donald Trump
is a champion
of the working class,
he's fighting the establishment,
taking on the elites to saying
his hush money scheme
was no big deal
because rich celebrities
do it all the time.
I hope Trump starts
incorporating
that at his rallies.
"You normies wouldn't
understand, but rich,
famous guys like me,
we have sex with porn stars
all the time.
All the time.
That's why I'm introducing
a bill to make it legal,
and we're calling it
the Concealing Relationships
and Monetary Enterprises Act,
aka the Crime Act.
Oh, dang it.
I've -- I've done it again.
Donald, you got to pay
attention to the letters.
They make an acronym.
They make an acronym."
But in the charging
document yesterday,
the district attorney
made it clear
that this case is
about a lot more
than just bookkeeping
or a sex scandal.
Trump funneled money
from his business
to a fixer to silence
an adult film star weeks
before an election
to help his campaign
and become the most
powerful man in the world.
It was a plot to hide
information from the public
and affect the outcome
of an election.
And by the way,
who knows if it would have?
Probably not. He probably could
have done a campaign event
in the lobby of the hotel
where he had the affair
and his supporters would have
still lined up to take selfies.
"I'm going to head up
to the room now any minute,
and then any minute after that,
I'll be right back down
to tell you how it went.
I don't think you'll have time
to run to the bathroom.
I'd stick around."
After his court appearance
yesterday,
Trump flew back to Mar-a-Lago
to give a speech to supporters
where he whined
about the usual bull[bleep]
and only briefly mentioned
the indictment.
-This fake case was brought
only to interfere
with the upcoming 2024 election,
and it should be
dropped immediately.
-Say whatever you want
about the charges,
but it's not a fake case,
I assure you.
You were really there
in a very real courtroom
facing very real felony charges,
although Trump is insane
so maybe he does think
the case is fake.
Maybe he thinks it's just
a "Truman Show" situation.
He's on a giant --
"It's a fake case,
and all I have to do
at the end
is walk up those stairs
and out that door."
But instead of just letting this
case play out, as it should,
Republicans are threatening
retaliation and revenge.
GOP Congressman James Comer
has said on Fox today
he's gotten multiple calls
from prosecutors in red states
looking for ways
to go after Joe Biden.
-I had two calls yesterday,
one from a county attorney
in Kentucky
and one from a county attorney
in Tennessee.
They -- they were Republican,
obviously.
Both states
are heavily Republican.
They want to know
if there are ways
they can go
after the Bidens now.
-I don't know.
Did Joe Biden pay hush money
to a porn star in Tennessee?
Because if not,
you're [bleep] out of luck, bud,
because that's not
how it works.
Trump's businesses
are in New York.
He committed the alleged
crime in New York,
New York has jurisdiction.
That's why Trump
is being charged
with falsifying business
records in Manhattan
and not, say, street racing
a Stingray in Chattanooga,
which if Joe Biden did,
by all means, arrest him.
If you can catch him.
Oh, those Biden boys!
We're gonna catch them
Biden boys.
[ Muttering ]
[ Laughter ]
Also these guys are --
they're just such morons.
You went on TV and confessed
that Republicans
are looking for ways to
manipulate the justice system
to go after Biden
as political revenge.
If those prosecutors
in Kentucky and Tennessee
ever do bring a case,
all the defense has to do
is play this clip
and the judge will say
the court rule is that you are,
and this is the legal term,
a massive [bleep].
Whatever, whatever else
you may think of this case,
the image of Trump
in that courthouse
sent a message
a former president
had to face the criminal
justice system
the same way anyone else would
under the same circumstances.
Trump may be pretending
he's enjoying all of this,
but I assure you, when he was
in that courthouse hearing
the charges read out loud,
his stomach...
-Dropped immediately.
-This has been A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]